well thank you very much Ravi and thank
you for the invitation to speak I'm
genuinely honored to be
afternoon as you just heard I'm the
founder and the president and chief
technology officer of tabula tabula is a
chip startup building a new kind of
programmable device basically for those
of you are not so technical a chip that
you can that can change its personality
after the fact where you can take after
manufacture this chip and say now you're
powering an MRI machine now you're
powering a networking device and so on
with those of you are technical with the
thing after FPGA and our longer term
agenda is to be the thing after
microprocessor to use this sort of
fabric this general approach to chip
architecture to be able to build devices
that have millions of objects running at
gigahertz rates with a software model
that allows one to program okay looking
back I've been lucky enough to be the
chief technology officer to poor
successful startups before this one two
of which went public in two of which we
sold and most recently as Robbie
mentioned I was the chief technology
officer at cadence a multi-billion
dollar company in the software for
designing jeff's I have to say I've
really enjoyed all of my companies but i
have to say also that tabula is the most
exciting and most and has been the most
fun of all now as I thought about what I
was going to talk about today I thought
well I can talk about the future of
computing which is a lot of what I've
been thinking about in the tabular
context or how to raise venture capital
libraries hundreds of millions of
dollars of venture capital in my life or
even do some magic although this
straitjacket is at home but decided
instead with this being an
entrepreneurship seminar that it would
be fun to try to offer some precepts
some suggestions to some of the
entrepreneurs of the future for at least
my perspective on how to do
entrepreneurship and then I realized
well at least looking at the students in
the room I'm roughly your parents age
and we all know that when your parents
say do this and don't do that nobody
pays any attention the the fact is your
parents have a context that's causing
them to make the suggestions that
they're making and lacking that context
they just seem like arbitrary precepts
and arbitrary principles and I didn't
want to step on that particular land
mine that said I do have 30 years of
experience starting in building
companies in a variety of fields and
wondered if I couldn't find some way of
talking about that entrepreneurship to
you guys so what I decided to do was to
use my own history as a framework and to
tell some stories based on the different
companies I've been a part of as a basis
for presenting sand themes
some lessons I've learned which I hope
the controversial at least in part and
yes some precepts with I hope a little
bit of context that I'll be providing by
showing where these different precepts
showed up in my own history and yes I'm
talking about looking back 30 years and
then I thought to myself wow when I was
a student if somebody had come to me who
was my parents age and said I'm going to
tell you Sonny about the future of
technology and entrepreneurship looking
back 30 years really when Harry Truman
was president that that context was in
some way going to be relevant to my
future but the fact is as quickly as
technology is moving and as quickly as
these companies are moving we're still
strongly influenced by technology
companies that were different that were
started 20 30 even 40 years ago Apple
which I think we'd all agree is still up
for front company was started in
nineteen seventy six so more than 35
years ago Oracle 1977 Microsoft which is
still having an influence in 1975 Cisco
which is still the basis of the hardware
of the internet 1984 so I 30 years ago
Adele also 1984 nvidia responsible for
this Sun this auditorium twenty years
ago and they're certainly a leading edge
company linux was developed in 1991 and
even google which i think we would all
agree is a forefront company is already
15 years old so i don't feel too guilty
about talking about stuff from twenty
and thirty years ago what I'm gonna try
in the stories that follow is to
illustrate a few beliefs such as the
following rather long list but I'll
repeat it at the end when it'll make
more sense i hope i think it's important
to try to change the world and i try to
run my life that way I've always started
with a problem rather than with the
technology a problem that I think
matters and then I think I might be able
to solve particularly well that that
matches whatever particular skills I
might be able to bring to the table to
the extent i've developed technologies
and i've tried to develop quite a few I
focused on technologies that I think
have broader applicability than their
original area of application so that I
can build a portfolio of technologies
and technical approaches that i can use
with each new thing that i try to take
on one of my core precepts is apply
everything you know about everything to
every problem you encounter and what
that means is I you want to try to find
ideas you can borrow from other domains
that you can apply to the problem at
hand the more stuff you know the more
readily you can do that so
learning all the time reading all the
time all kinds of stuff is important
because you never know where you're
going to see a connection that you
didn't see before that perhaps nobody
else saw before I also think it's
important to seek rich and compelling
metaphors I think if you can find the
right way to look at something a good
metaphor for the problem that you're
working on the math and technology and
computer science will follow I think
it's important to challenge assumptions
other people's assumptions and your own
all the time and it's not enough to have
good ideas you've got to build great
products craft matters infrastructure
matters they're worth investing in make
your product sparkle and and have their
physical implementation manifest what
you think is beautiful about the
underlying idea we direct your fear you
know when Michael Jordan was shooting
the baskets I can't imagine he was
thinking to himself oh my god what if I
missed this shot i'm looking idiot on
television just shoot the damn basket i
focus your energy on the thing you're
actually working on and you can give a
hundred percent of your effort to that
rather than protecting your ego just in
case it's important to surround yourself
with great teams most of the things one
wants to take on require a whole bunch
of people and that team should be
talented passionate should be teaching
you stuff and learning stuff from you
and also they better be nice you're
going to spend a lot of time with them
and it's easy to undervalue niceness but
it actually matters and finally
challenge yourself and your colleagues
and have fun okay with that long list
let me jump in i started my
undergraduate career doing mathematics
at Princeton and I I was okay at it but
at a certain point I had this horrifying
thought suppose it turns out that i'm
great at mathematics and i'm going to
publish papers in algebraic number
theory that six people in the world can
understand what what kind of life is
that and i felt for myself that wasn't
enough leverage and it made me not want
to be a professional mathematician now
it also happens that the Apple two came
out when I was a freshman in college and
I could see immediately that was going
to change everything that computing was
going to become pervasive that I needed
to know more about this so I bought an
early Apple two became it really expert
with the Apple 2 and did consulting with
the Educational Testing Service the
company that makes SATs in fact my work
there is on their front page the cover
of their annual report in 1981 I think
but I also could see I was interested in
lots of different
that computing was going to pervade a
lot of different stuff so i figured i
could use computing to change careers
whenever I felt like it and I run my
life exactly that way and that's why I
switched to electro engineering and
computer science the first job after
school was at a startup company a really
ambitious startup company called trilogy
which was started by G Nam doll and I
joined them in 1982 as a contractor I
trilogy was doing what's called wafer
scale integration trying to make chips
that were ten centimeters on the side
and trying to build an ibm-compatible
mainframe a more reasonable thing to do
in 1982 then now I using such technology
and they would say they made me an offer
I couldn't refuse and and convinced me
to join them as a contractor in order to
build this complicated chip and these
complicated chips in this complicated
system they had to simulate everything
and so they had lots and lots and lots
of schematic diagrams describing the
system they were trying to build and
they would simulate that system with
what's called the logic simulator they
asked me to write a compiler for the
language that controlled their logic
simulator fine when I looked at what
they were trying to do with simulation I
could see that simulating the schematic
diagrams and and running programs were
really the same thing in disguise yes
schematic diagrams are in a stranger
computer language than c or in that in
those days pascal but there were
programs nonetheless and so it occurred
to me that if only i could up convert
the schematic diagrams into pascal
programs I could use a Pascal compiler
with its all the base optimizations and
produce a custom simulator for
everything one wanted to simulate that
would be much much higher performance
and much simpler and sure enough we
built this thing and it was 700 times
faster than this emulator that preceded
and the technique we developed now
called compiled code logic simulation is
still 30 years later the standard
technique for logic simulation the
things to observe here are that the
parts of the system that hadn't been
fully designed could still be described
and see your Pascal and so it allowed
one to combine low-level descriptions of
the parts of the hardware that we're
fully understood in schematics and and
abstract descriptions of the rest of the
system and simulate them all together to
get high performance and also high
generality that metaphor of viewing
schematics as programs was the key that
drove the whole effort and craft matters
i would say in retro
maybe a hundred exit that 700 x came
from the idea of compile code and the
remaining seven X is that we coded it
fanatically very very very carefully to
get all the performance out of it it's
important to build things carefully and
well now one of the things from my days
at trilogy is that in 1983 there was an
article in science on what's now called
simulated annealing a at that time
brand-new general-purpose combinatorial
optimization technology so a way of
taking a function with a hundred
thousand variables a very complex
function and be able to try to find a
near global optimum the moment I saw the
paper I could see this was going to be a
transformative technology and then I
needed to learn a lot about it the
metaphor basically their metaphor is you
have this hundred thousand variable
function imagine that you represent this
by a hundred thousand particles where
the energy function of that system of
particles matches the function you're
trying to optimize simulate the system
in a very high temperature and then very
slowly cool it down until the whole
thing coalesces into a very low energy
crystal I this struck me is a really
beautiful and powerful idea but I also
wanted to challenge their assumptions
because the fact is that the next level
the questions were wanted to ask in my
opinion were all inadequately answered
in those early influential papers really
what temperature should just start at
how much interchanges temperature by how
do you decide when you should change the
temperature when should you stop what
kinds of transformations should you do
etc etc etc so I started working on the
mathematics for that starting with their
metaphor and trying to build the
technology for a general for general
purpose optimization now this served me
well because even though trilogy went
public it became clear that they weren't
going to be the transformative company
we had all hoped and so with four other
folks three of whom were colleagues a
tangent including my boss there we
started a company called tangent at
which I became the CTO that tangent was
a company that built software for chip
design at that time there was the very
beginning of a sea change in chip design
before this time roughly the way people
would design chips is that somebody
would manually specify where every
transistor around the trip was going to
go where every wire was going on the gym
going to go on the trip completely crazy
I'll be it obviously doesn't scale and
so somebody had the clever idea of well
why don't we have small collections of
transistors to build basic functions
like and it
and plus and we're going to put them in
a standard library of cells cells that
can go in rows and we're going to have
rows of these components separated by
empty spaces called channels where we're
going to put the wires rows of
components wires rows of components
wires as a way of making it easier to
assemble chips and the folks that
started tangent realized if only we
could automate that procedure automate
the placement of where the cells were
going to go and the routing of where the
wires were going to go we could make it
possible for anybody to design a chip
quickly and really have an impact on the
electronics industry so I even though I
knew absolutely nothing about placement
or routing they made me the CTO of this
company and so I spent the summer of
nineteen eighty-four reading what was at
that time the entire literature on
placement and routing I got all the
proceedings from all of the relevant
conferences and I SAT by the pool at my
apartment complex with five feet of of
tomes and just read from read from one
end to the other and then we jumped in
and try to build our first product tan
cell which as it turns out despite its
coming from 1984 in 1985 has been pretty
influential we built the first
commercial analytical placer which is
now the standard technique for
large-scale placement today 30 years
later we built the first commercial
adaptive simulated annealing system all
that math I've been doing on annealing
paid off and I was able to use it to do
optimization within 10 so and it's that
too is still used today and was very
popularly for about 20 years so I try to
build technologies with leverage that
general purpose optimization I was able
to apply to the special purpose problem
of placing cells we had the first
commercial timing driven place in route
system the first congestion based place
and route system these are all the
standard philosophies for chip design
even even still today unfortunately even
though we built and sell it worked it
was a good product it was beating other
products that were people were trying to
develop it didn't matter we were ahead
of the market and that sea change to
move to cells in this way while it did
happen didn't happen to let three years
after we built an cell so it was hard to
make a really successful business out of
this and we had to change course a
little bit well it turns out there was
another see change happening in chips
right about this time this is 86 or so
now we're the folks who manufacture
chips figure it out ways that they could
put multiple levels of wiring above the
transistors rather than beside the
transistors to try to fill the entire
trip with these cells a sea of cells or
sea of gates as it came
to be called you have this large jigsaw
puzzle worth of of cells filling up the
space and then lots and lots of wires on
top well that problem looked much harder
than how to place components arose
nobody knew how to solve it the people
who invented that technology to make it
possible to manufacture people and other
companies we didn't know how to solve it
either I definitely didn't know how to
solve it either but I did know that we
had a general purpose optimization
technology that we could use as a bit of
a science laboratory to figure out how
best to attack a difficult problem like
this and it paid off we actually figured
out how to do it and we invented modern
what's called area-based place around
the the basis of the technology for how
people have laid out ships ever since we
basically took that general
combinatorial optimization technology
that old annealing stuff and kept
evolving in and evolving in and refining
it and improving it and it ended up
being powerful enough to solve this
problem we also built it on top of very
carefully constructed scalable
infrastructure at that time people were
making ships with 5,000 or 10,000 cells
but it wasn't very long thereafter that
there were 200,000 or 300,000 cells but
we built a system that was able to scale
enough that we were able to ride that
wave and we more than doubled the
capacity of what you could put on a chip
of a given size with tan gate that
product so that became quite successful
which in turn caused tangent to be
acquired by cadence very large company
and the cadence products from the late
80s Early 90s of gate ensemble cell
ensemble which generated more than three
billion dollars in revenue all have tan
gate inside them as it turns out I
didn't stay at cadence very long I
started a biotech company instead now
that sounds a little bit strange perhaps
but it but it's less strange than it
sounds see while I was working on tan
gate this is 86 87 is when people first
started talking about the Human Genome
Project and I thought well this is going
to be transformative this is going to be
incredibly important and I don't know
anything about it so I went to the
Stanford bookstore and got a book on
general chemistry and organic chemistry
and physical chemistry and molecular
biology and genetics is basically over
the course of the next couple of years
tried to teach myself chemistry biology
genetics at least at an undergraduate
level after doing this for a couple of
years I thought well truly the problem
of discovering Pharmaceuticals has been
revolutionized by computer aided design
in the same way the chip design has been
but no that wasn't the case at all while
they were very forward-thinking people
like Michael Levitt here at Stanford who
we're simulating molecules on the screen
and doing science with the computer
nobody was attacking the engineering
problem of engineering a pharmaceutical
that has given properties using
significant help from computation and I
thought to myself well why don't I take
all the ideas that I've been using to
engineer chips to engineer molecules the
people who are doing this design of
molecules are scientists who look at the
molecules and think maybe I'll replace
that nitrogen of the carbon and see if
that makes my molecule more active and
while they're brilliant scientists in
many cases and know far more chemistry
than I will ever know they weren't
engineers and they were trying to solve
an engineering problem without using an
engineering discipline so to me
engineering whether you're engineering a
bridge engineering a chip engineering
software or engineering a molecule is at
its core the same stuff I think there
are five main pillars to how engineering
works optimization visualization
representation generalization which is
machine learning and simulation and in
the case of drug discovery I figured I
could use my placement and routing
background treating the atoms as these
cells and treating the bonds as wires to
try to find low energy structures for
molecules with an optimization
technology and or it for visualization
you see chemists play with these plastic
models to get a feel for how the
molecules work but I realized with the
computer we could make the plastic model
actually simulate the correct forces on
the mount on the molecule give real
intuition about what I'm all you would
really do but I wanted to provide an
interface where you could grab the
molecule on this Queen and play with it
now you know how when you're on the web
and you see something in 3d and you move
your mouse and it causes the thing to
rotate we were the first product to have
that in it the virtual trackball for
representation I'd had lots of practice
building huge databases for chip
information we use the same ideas to
build molecular databases with billions
of molecules in them and those molecular
database structures are still used today
generalization we were perhaps the first
to apply machine learning to the problem
of drug discovery and we built a system
called hypothesis generation that
attempted to generate scientific
explanations for the data that had been
observed the chemists would give us the
molecules they had tried how active they
appeared to be and we would construct
comprehensible models that were ranked
models of possible explanations of the
data that had been observed and then
simulation use
those models to estimate activity from
those hypotheses I know I'm getting a
little bit technical back that off in
just a second parenthetically i went to
venture capitalists try to raise money
for this company and mike 11 of all
people was brought in to do due
diligence on me as you might know he
just won the nobel prize in chemistry
here you see her at Stanford and He
blessed it thankfully and we did get the
company funded but I still remember this
is more than 20 years ago I still
remember one of the questions he asked
me which is which would you rather do
win the nobel prize in chemistry or make
five million dollars and I thought for a
little while and I said I think I'd
rather make the five million dollars
well evidently he made the other choice
and it worked out for her so so the bio
cad technology that was my company bio
cad I that technology still widely used
we sold by OCAD the company to a company
called excel wrist which still exists
and is public one of the things I
realized in doing this biotech stuff is
I was providing software for other
people to design drugs but if you've got
a design technology that's actually
superior why would you give it to
anybody else why not use it to design
stuff yourself and so I started in the
pharmaceutical company so in mid 90s now
I started a company called combi him and
where I was his chief technology officer
and this was an attempt that changed the
world to try to build a better scheme
for generating molecules the basic idea
from combi cam was something I had
thought of while I was still at bio CAD
but didn't have a way to execute it by
OCAD it's an idea that I called
mastermind and I'm not going to dive too
far into this but I at least want to
give a sense of it I metaphors I think
are really important the 30 second tour
of biochemistry and metabolism is as
follows you have in your body large
molecules as molecules go made of
protein and those large molecules pick
up smaller molecules on the scale of
molecules and do chemistry on them so it
breaks the bonds makes and bonds and so
on and by a series of such
transformations you can transform food
into energy for example or you can raise
or lower your blood pressure and so on
the way most pharmaceuticals work is the
idea is you can treat these large
molecules as locks that are picking up a
small key and then trained changing it
and handing it to the next guy hand to
get to the next guy what you want to do
is find some luck where if you impede
just that lock you prevent it from doing
its job
by stuffing some gum in the malach you
selectively interfere with one
biological process like raising blood
pressure the catch is at least in those
days you don't get to see the lock you
have a biological test of some sort that
i'll tell you how well the key fits the
lock but not which parts of the keyword
good parts nor what the lock looks like
how are you going to design a molecule
under those circumstances and I realized
this is rather like the game master mind
where somebody has a sequence of colored
marbles that are hidden from you and
you've got to determine what that
sequence of marbles is so you create a
sequence of colored marbles and the
other person tells you here's how many
of your marbles were correct
approximately so it gives you a score
for how well you did without telling
which telling you which part of your
guess was a good part if you're clever
enough in designing your experiments
which sequences you provide and clever
enough in doing the inference based on
the answers you get back you can in fact
infer in a systematic way what secrets
of colors was hidden from you well you
can use very analogous strategy to try
to design a key for a lot you can't see
you make a bunch of keys you try those
keys you see how well they fit and you
use what you learned to pick the most
informative next set of keys you couple
an experimental design procedure to
design an informative collection of keys
with an inference procedure they try to
learn from that collection of keys and
the catch of course is I the other guy
can lie in this game biological assays
are very unreliable so I want to play
the sort of 20 questions like game but
you have some probability of lying well
it turns out that problem has a
technical solution and we worked it out
and we ended up hiring a bunch of
chemists and a bunch of computer
scientists and we built this mastermind
like system that we call the discovery
engine where we did what's now called
active learning it's something we
invented independently although a couple
of years after Dana Anglo and thought of
it at Yale no web in those days that's
why I didn't know that until much later
and it turns out that by coupling
experimental design with inference you
can basically build an automated
scientist what we did in effect was
automate the scientific method by the
application of modern statistics and
modern computer scientists and it worked
in those days the biggest drug company
was Merck they took seven years on
average to discover a drug and their
success rate was about one in seven
tries our success rate was 11 out of 12
and our longest project to call me 13
months
average was less than a year so it
worked and we discovered 11 different
pharmaceutical candidates in a whole
bunch of different areas doing drug
discovery for hire for big drug
companies I based on this mastermind
metaphor we were even beginning to apply
this technology to materials designed
the company went public we did a
partnership with DuPont pharmaceuticals
they were impressed enough they bought
the company we help them discover a
couple of drugs and that impressed
bristol-myers squibb enough they bought
that company for seven point eight
billion dollars and that was time for me
to go do something else and in fact i
returned to chip design and i'm not
going to spend too much time on this i
joined a company called simplex another
company in software for chip design
where i became its CTO and i'll really
say about simplex I is that I took the
machine learning technology that i had
developed in a biotech setting and just
as I had with bio cat taking chip ideas
and applied them to biometry this time I
took the stuff I did for drug discovery
and applied it back to chips no one had
applied machine learning technologies
for a chip design before as far as we
could tell well it turns out it worked
wonderfully we were able to infer
automatically models using this sort of
mastermind idea that could estimate with
much higher accuracy what the
performance of things on a trip were
going to be we were five times as
accurate as what preceded us we were a
hundred times as fast as what preceded
us this is the leverage of developing
technologies with brought out the
cabella t general purpose optimization
technology general purpose machine
learning technology general purpose
active learning technology because they
can be applied to problem after problem
after problem and give you really
powerful general-purpose tools to attack
even these really guy scary difficult
problems at simply certainly we were
surrounded by a wonderful team as well
and the other thing we took on besides
this higher accuracy business is we
challenged the decades-old assumption
that the wires on chips are allowed to
be only horizontal or vertical we
realized that if only you could have
other directions suppose you could have
horizontal and vertical and horizontal
and vertical that is to say and also 45
degrees at 135 degrees so have different
layers that were that had four different
directions you could build much smaller
much faster much lower power trips
I and there were all kinds of bogus
reasons oh you can't do this because
none of which turned out to be real and
so we had to reinvent the entire flow
from front to back and something I 150
patents came out of that not all of my
mind but a whole bunch from that from
that effort and we developed the scheme
that generalized chip designed to
include diagonal wires as well as
horizontal and vertical ones we had an
IPO in 2001 it was the most successful
IPO of 2001 and then a 2002 we were
required by cadence from which it
appears there's no escape if you do
check design and and and I became
cadences Co CTO now my job at cadence
was to try to find a vision for the
future of cadence how do we make cadence
a ten times bigger company than it used
to be now cadence sells software for
people to design ships with but the kind
of chips people design with kaden
software are special purpose chips for
special purpose applications a chip in
your cell phone a chip in a cisco router
and so on that's becoming so
time-consuming and so difficult even the
big companies are scared of it and I
started to worry that it might not be
the best thing for kids as long-term
future to make such a to be so dependent
on people always jumping to the next
technology and and continuing to design
at a rapid rate special-purpose chips I
wondered couldn't you have a
programmable chip couldn't you have a
more general purpose chip where you can
use the same chip for many applications
by having it change it by changing its
personality and as it turns out that
we're all ready to substantial companies
doing exactly that who have a technology
called fpgas that are basically
programmable chips where you can imbue
them with a different personality after
their manufacture and I thought this is
fantastic I FPGAs are going to be part
of part of the future and then I looked
into them in more detail what I found
was yes programmability is fantastic and
kudos to the FPGA companies for for
creating it but the overhead for
providing that program ability is
absolutely intolerable it turns out that
both then and now the FPGA companies
only provide about five percent of the
market for special purpose chips and the
reason is that the overhead for
programmability makes those programmable
chips incredibly large incredibly
expensive incredibly slow so the idea is
beautiful the execution not so much and
it led me to wonder all right can we do
better can I think of a way of building
a better programmable trip
vga and it turns out and came up with a
way to do it and realized that the
architecture that made it possible to
build a better programmable device one
that's much denser much faster that
provides the performance of a special
purpose chip and not too much overhead
for the programmability while still
preserving full programmability that
same architecture could be used for a
computer and not just for a special
purpose chip that it provided the basis
for a post von Neumann a bunch of your
computer science people a post von
Neumann computer something where you
would have a million computing elements
or 10 million computing elements running
at gigahertz rates where you can still
program this in a software like way so
while I really wasn't going to do a
fifth company I just saw this
opportunity first of all the hundred
billion dollar opportunity for ships but
also the chance to build a computer that
went beyond the microprocessor and I had
to do it so I left cadence and I spent a
few months in my living room trying to
figure out how this was going to work
and invented a series of technologies
that we now call space time and insight
and every where and when often founded
tabula of which I'm currently the
president and chief technology officer
that is building in fact a better
programmable device that can compete not
just with these FPGA sort of classical
programmable devices but even with
special purpose devices for a wide wide
range of applications but frankly my
real agenda and please don't tell anyone
is to build a better computer and and
and to use this technology over the next
several years to try to build a
framework to get out of the cereal I
know I'm on mindset into a into a better
computing environment ok let me take a
step back literally I you might wonder
why do why do I bother starting
companies and my answer to that is
because I know I'm gonna be dead soon I
know you're going to be dead soon and
changing the world is really important
to me and this is a way to do that it's
also because frankly I think almost all
products are just lousy even products
that are supposed to be good are just
lousy and it drives me crazy and and
there are only so many of those products
that any one of us can reasonably take
on but I've tried to take on aspects of
products we engineer that I think are
engineered in a mediocre way and to
apply some technology to make them
better at least for my own taste but
another reason I start companies is
because Frank
it's fun it's it's incredibly exciting
at least to me I not just to build
products which you can do in any company
but to build the culture itself when you
have a small company you can control
collectively what does it feel like to
work at that company what kind of people
work at this company make it a place
that's a fun place to be around and it
is a surprisingly intimate exercise
you're not only building art in some
sense collectively building wonderful
products and building the company but
there's the intellectual challenge of
working with these colleagues and
frankly the emotional challenge of being
you spending many hours a day in many
many weeks at this at this effort it's a
really intense experience and a
wonderful one and I'm still close with
many of the people at my previous
companies because it's just it's hard to
describe there's an intensity to it
that's unique and to me wonderful you
might also wonder well how do I choose
which company i'm going to start and i
hope it's clear from this rapid fire
walk through my history that i've always
tried to solve a problem that matters
excuse me whose solution matches my
particular skill set I've also tried to
find a problem with the solution will
give me leverage to solve other problems
down the road so general tools I can use
for the wrong so looking at tangent the
the idea was to help folks implement
complex chips that was the problem we
went after but underneath we developed
general-purpose large-scale optimization
machinery that I've used in all kinds of
different applications at bio CAD the
goal was to help people discover
pharmaceuticals more quickly but we
developed the general-purpose body of
machine learning technology that again
it served me in many different areas at
comic em we ourselves discovered
pharmaceutical quickly and there the
technique was to automate the scientific
method to develop general-purpose active
learning so we could have a scientist in
a box to attack a wide range of
scientific problems that came up at
simplex the objective was to help folks
implement denser and faster and lower
power chips but we have to reinvent the
entire ship implementation flow to deal
with diagonal wires and ended up with
150 plus patents as a result invented
all kinds of stuff and a tabula the
probable trying to solve is to help
folks to design high performance chips
quickly and inexpensively with the
underlying technology we're trying to
develop of building a scalable post von
Neumann computer and its associated
software so let me touch on a couple of
the lessons that at least I've learned
from the experience to date first I
think it's valuable to try to make
connections that haven't been made
before even Albert Einstein is quoted as
saying the very few ideas are made of
whole cloth so we a lot read widely and
try to find good metaphors that allow
you to look at this problem as just a
funny way of looking at this other
problem I so you can borrow ideas from
all over the place and they're not even
necessarily other scientific ideas ways
of looking at problems will be a guide
for what kind of math did you use what
kind of technology should you use and so
on it I think metaphors are underrated
and I think their fundamental another
point I'll make is that I've learned
that making a decision at all and making
it quickly and clearly often matters
more than making the right decision the
fact of the matter is you're just not
that smart and I'm not that smart and
Steve Jobs wasn't that smart we work on
incredibly complicated stuff in an
incredibly complicated ecosystem but the
good news is that ecosystem is full of
local Optima you know I just came back
from safari in Africa just a few weeks
ago and and you see all kinds of really
bizarre creatures when you're on safari
in Africa you see you know giraffes with
their long necks and elephants with
their long trunks and the and the
rhinoceros with their horns warthogs
very strange-looking animals and so on
well let's take the Warthog know the
word height is not a lion and it's not a
leopard but it's been successful with
being a warthog for at least 25 or 30
million years it's found in each it is
it is a successful business so to speak
in the ecosystem of the animals that are
on the sadhana and yeah it's possible
but the original warthogs looked more
like pigs and then they were being eaten
too frequently by lions and leopards and
so some of them are lucky enough to have
tusks to defend themselves excellent so
so so release 2 point 0 had had had
tusks and allowed them to be more
effective it being warthogs you don't
have to be a leopard you can be a
warthog and build a really successful
business if you're willing to respond to
your environment quickly the key is
figure out what you want to be go after
that and if you see that the environment
changes in front of you or the
you picked wrong change course a little
bit there are local Optima to be found
all over the place you don't have to be
in this ridiculously farsighted
visionary to see the whole picture at
once have a picture have a vision but be
prepared to change your mind another
thing I'll say in the hope of being
tiniest bit controversial is to some
extent I think data is overrated now
obviously being a bit waggish about this
in a narrow domain you're trying to
improve an algorithm of course data is
fundamental right you I take
measurements how else can you tell how
you're doing but the more complex the
problem we're going after the less data
is going to help if you're trying to
make a big decision about the direction
of your company you cannot get enough
data soon enough to make that decision
well and if you sit on your hands and
wait in the hope that you'll get enough
data to be able to make that decision
correctly you'll be too late and your
best the market I you at some at some
level just need to go for it and see
what happens and yes when the market
responds change course be nimble coolly
you don't want to have blinders on but
but it's easy to get paralyzed by trying
to gather too much data too soon and I
think engineers as a community to easily
fall into that really toxic trap and
then last of these in my opinion the
most fun you can have it work is that a
change the world startup I you're going
to be dead soon make a difference I to
paraphrase a recent movie a million
dollars isn't cool well I think a
billion dollars isn't cruel either
changing the world that's what's cool
and if you change the world and do it in
some significant way the money is going
to come make a difference and and to
that end it's not enough that you
tolerate the uncertainty of building a
company and tolerate the uncertainty of
a startup you've got a revel in it it's
like being in the roller coaster when
you put your arms up and go I I it has
to be fun that you don't know it has to
be fun that you have to respond to the
uncertainty that's around you of
building a company of building great
products of building a team and of
changing the world that's part of the
thrill of it and there's just nothing
like it as far as I'm concerned all
right before I wrap up let me go back
over this list of the precepts I started
this talk with now that you have a
little context for why I believe them as
I hope this talk has made clear so far I
tried very hard to change the world
that's very important to me and I hope
it's important to you I've always
started with a problem that I think
matters and that I think i can solve
well that is that place to my particular
knowledge base in my a mic reticular
skills in developing technologies I've
tried to develop ones that have
applicability beyond the current
application to build a portfolio of rich
I technologies that I can then apply to
another problem I see next and as I
mentioned early in the talked what if my
core precepts is apply everything you
know about everything to every problem
you encounter so read a lot seek rich
compelling metaphors as a way of looking
at problems in new ways and and by and
by a new perspectives it's important
always to learn but it's also important
always to teach it's also part of the
fun of being in a startup company is
that that constant back-and-forth
teaching is part of the thrill surround
yourself with a great team people who
are talented people who are passionate
and people who are nice I got to tell
you I wasn't it wasn't until I was 40 I
think that I really embraced that having
people that are nice is incredibly
important I or going to make a little
too easily hired people that were
clearly brilliant and not necessarily
fun to work work with and at a certain
point you just say you know life's too
short constantly challenge assumptions
including your own assumptions make
great products craft matters
infrastructure matters invest in both
because it make your product sparkle we
direct your fear use whatever I
protection your you go you are going to
use that energy apply it towards the
problem and it'll make you stronger
attacking that problem than you yourself
think you are give a hundred percent in
that sense challenge yourself and your
colleagues and have fun revel in the
adventure so before I end and turn this
over to you guys I want to add a couple
of precepts from someone who had a
tremendous influence on me and that's my
father my father was a brilliant
technologist and a brilliant executive
and we were extremely close and he
taught me many many things and sadly he
died when I was 13 years old but before
that he taught me many precepts that
have served me well all this time I
among them and I can remember even being
five years old and hearing him say this
is pink work you love because you're
going to spend more time doing
that than anything else in your life
more than with your family more than
sleeping more than doing any of your
hobbies pick something you love and the
second which he relieved to his dying
breath he's always try your best and
I've always striven to do that as well
all right with that thank you so much
for your attention and I'll take
whatever questions you might have
you think you do that innovative
companies and true innovation comes out
through the new things or can it truly
or can it come out of making existing
innovation is better so if I understand
the question you're saying can I can
innovation is innovation always about
creating new things or can it be based
on the existing innovations and making
them better I certainly patency patency
stuff so I I think that they that that
question lives on a spectrum rather than
being a pair of opposites I as i said
earlier even Einstein says that almost
nothing isn't at that out of whole cloth
the fact is you're always standing on
the shoulders of giants and midgets both
I in trying to construct better
technologies you're always borrowing
ideas and making connections people
haven't made so to the extent so I do
think it's possible to start with a
pre-existing ID and a pre-existing
technology if you can extend it in some
unexpected way applying it to a new
domain finding some new wrinkle on it
making a connection between this and
that in fact almost all of the patents I
would venture to say all of the patents
in the Patent Office but certainly
almost all of them are of the form one
of these things people already knew
about with this particular thing at in
on top of it sometimes it's a dramatic
thing and that's cool and sometimes it
isn't and that's okay see if a secure
case you a question on the fear of
jumping into something unknown shirks I
think what's amazing for for me is how
you've jumped into these unknown fields
full wholeheartedly what advice do you
have for students or people who are
prospective founders who are grappling
with the fear of jumping into something
that they don't know and also just
thinking about the downside risk of
jumping into entrepreneurship any any
tactical advice for getting over fear
what I was doing oh I'll say a couple of
things about that um the first is and
this has always kind of made me laugh as
long as I've lived in Silicon Valley
which is you know 30-plus years now
fortunately for the people who live
around here people who don't live around
here generally speaking
to death to start the kinds of crazy
companies that people are who they were
out here start they overestimate the
true downside of blowing it so let's go
through the exercise so you go ahead and
you start a company and you give it your
all and you work on it for three years
and and and and at that point you can
probably tell whether there might be
something there or not and let's imagine
there isn't and the thing just fails
presumably you were somebody pretty
smart and motivated you got the thing
funded you managed to build a team you
managed to build a product you're going
to get another job you'll have to start
another company you'll be able to join
another company somewhere else the
objective risk at least early in your
careers which is where essentially all
of you are the objective risk is low the
worst thing that'll happen to you is
okay so you'll get another job we going
to be reasonably paid while you're out
that startup you're going to learn a lot
the experience of trying to build a
company and if trying to figure out how
to make it fly will serve you whether
that company flies high or not says it
so I think people vastly overestimate
the true risk that they're taking now
with that said I don't really know a way
to say this to you that will that you'll
really be able to internalize because I
know I wouldn't have accepted it at your
age except having experienced it myself
but i'll try to say this anyway what i
have found for myself in being willing
really to take the plunge really not to
protect my own ego really to think i'm
going to bed at all and if it fails i'm
going to feel terrible I is that I'm
able to do things that I myself don't
think I can do what I found the first
time I did that was that I problems that
looked that I thought were too hard for
me I were nearer to my grasp than I
thought because the third of my effort
third of my whatever of my effort that I
was spending protecting myself Oh what
if this goes wrong well that's stewing
about all the things that could go wrong
by taking that third of my effort and
applying it to the problem i was now one
and a half times as powerful as i would
have been if I hadn't done that and I
found that it that it was like a
superpower that ended up making me and
my team in whom I inculcated the same
idea it made us a more powerful
engineering team than we thought we were
so I realized that unless you've done
this that might not resonate
but it certainly matches my own
experience and the brainchild with
everything you did and also being a
businessman at being the front of these
companies how did you find the balance
between being the businessman and being
the innovator and was there ever a time
that maybe being a businessman is
difficult the question is how did I
strike a balance between being a
business person than being an innovator
and that I ever have difficulty I
striking that balance not having enough
time for both it's a good question and
the fact is my emphasis has been much
more on the technology side than it has
been on the pure business side I have in
fact personally raised a lot of the
money at all of my different companies I
because I come across as the maniac you
see before you with a certain level of
passion about the stuff I'm working on
and when they bring in experts to look
at what we're doing it helps the
potential investor see that we know what
we're talking about but in fact i have
chosen that at almost all of my
companies to bring in business people
not because i didn't think i could do
the business part honestly but because
that's not where i get the weight is
leverage there are other people who were
greated business and in fact some who
are way better at it than I am I I have
more alive more personal leverage I
think working on working on technology
so with that said as it happens looking
at tabula specifically when I started
the company I was CEO and and I'm a CEO
and CTO and in retrospect that was a
mistake I because for exactly the reason
you're implying I simply couldn't spend
enough time on the two different things
and if I had to do it over again I would
have to choose differently at the very
least I would have built more of an
executive staff sooner with be piece of
engineering and stuff like that or I
eventually brought in a world-class CEO
where was our CEO today Dennis segars
and he and I are partners where he's the
CEO and I'm effectively the CTO but I
waited longer than I should have to do
that and and tabula took longer than it
ought to have in part because I made
that bad as her English educate yourself
in the number of different fields which
were not what you originally learned
about in university how do you go about
doing that so the question was I taught
myself about areas that I didn't learn
about in college how do I go about doing
that
I would wager you already know the
answer to that question I would wager
that in the classes you're taking that
much of the teaching you're doing
despite the excellent teaching obviously
at Stanford much of the teaching you're
doing is teaching of yourself you take
text books and study them you look at
things on the web etc and I do a lot of
that as well I just I love ideas I love
learning new stuff and and and I
approach this without any sort of magic
I just you know read papers read
textbooks I but but I really really
enjoyed it so so so so I spend a
tremendous effort on it because of the
thrill of learning new metaphors
learning new ideas being able to walk in
Galileo's shoes for just a moment and
see how easy he saw the world that kind
of stuff yeah it's the right time to
start a company and it's the right time
to start a company Wow I'll tell you at
least how I've done this it took a good
question you know and i'll give it a
serious answer for all of my stalking
about you know redirect your fear and i
believe that in it I think it's true I
am much more careful than it would
appear to an outsider in the companies
that I've started the fact is before
I've started any of my companies I was
sure I the venture capitalist who
invested weren't necessarily sure the
team that joined with me weren't
necessarily sure I was sure and I don't
say that frivolously at all the fact is
for example with tabula which is really
involved technology I spent months doing
nothing but thinking about that to work
out not all of the problems certainly
the hundreds of people have been working
with have contributed immensely to this
project over the last year's but at
least the top level problems I got far
enough to convince myself I knew I had a
solution that would work that I knew
that there weren't giant obstacles in
the way and that I could see that there
was a finish line out there even if I
hadn't mapped it all the way up I waited
till I was sure and before I put my ass
on the line and go to a venture
capitalist and say give me millions and
millions of dollars I in my heart of
hearts I I can't be certain the company
will succeed that's
there are so many exogenous horses there
that I can't control but I can at least
be sure the thing I'm saying I can
deliver I can deliver I I know how to
build it I know what's going to work I
know it's going to be better than any of
solutions I've apparently encountered I
spend a long time dotting the i's on
where I see the endogenous risks of can
we built this product how much
engineering effort is it going to take
how hard are these technical problems
really before I before I make the wager
but once I'm once i know i can deliver
it then it's really a matter of do i
think there's a market there and that
sometimes you can tell and sometimes you
can't it sort of depends i try to ask
experts and and and get at least some
feel for it for my comments about data
before there's only so much you can
learn but I at least try to have
conversations with prospective customers
and and and other experts in the field
to get some feel for it but once i know
i can build it and once i have some
sense that if i could build it there
would be something there at least for me
that's when i go for it company right
out of college or would you go through
an education phase of learning under
somebody else and then an execution
phase of starting something else it
depends III don't think there's anything
wrong with starting a company all right
out of college I think it depends if you
have an idea and and where you can tell
you have something that's technically
sound well you can tell you're solving a
problem that matters you can tell you
how to technically sound solution for
attacking it and you have at least some
reason to believe by talking to others
that if you could only build this thing
it would solve the problem and it would
make a difference why not I mean I think
there is value in in apprentice thing as
it were underneath people for a couple
of years but I don't know that it's
fundamentally required even though i see
that you in it yeah good start this
company but between that and having a
finished product there's some different
roads you go down so can you talk about
what you've done to move faster through
the bill measure learns feedback loop
just try to drive to finished product
when we try to parrot that back the the
the path from having an idea to having
an actually finished product can be full
of twists and turns what have i done to
try to accelerate that that path of
being able to learn efficiently
part of this a big part of this I think
is being really scientific about it that
is many engineers smart though they are
aren't systematic in their experiments
they do a run let's say in the software
world they'll do a run and they'll call
that an experiment know what hypothesis
are you testing what are you going after
what you hope to learn from this you
have limited resources users versus
efficiently by asking the best question
you can think to ask so so I try to
mitigate what I see as the risks as
quickly as possible by building
prototypes do a lot of prototyping I
reading papers so I can learn from other
successes and failures and and trying to
diagnose carefully if something didn't
turn out the way I expected I really try
to dig to the bottom of it and I
encourage my colleagues to do the same
why didn't this work there's something
we're not understanding why not with
what's wrong with our with our approach
so if you can make every step you take
count it actually doesn't take that many
steps often to get to something that
works that's the best I can do yeah
something more than once you've jumped
into entirely new industries and not
yourself love thinks I'm required to
innovate in that space sour cherries has
a student what's the value in an
institutionalized education education
like you had a Princeton having an
awesome man all right so the question is
that more than once I seem to have
switched fields by teaching myself stuff
so given that I what was the value of
institutionalized education of this
route that I had ever had at Princeton
indescribable I going to Princeton was
utterly wonderful as I imagined that
going to Stanford is for all kinds of
reasons first of all I being able to
spend a substantial fraction of my time
four years in a row study learning all
kinds of crazy stuff and it took course
is all over the place and all kinds of
crazy stuff besides math a computer
science i mean really all kinds of crazy
stuff but i also met tons of smart
people and I'd love to the fact the
thing I love most in some ways about
president is I met all these people who
were every bit as passionate about I
ancient Greece or contemporary music as
i was about math and then electronic a
computer science so they would hold
forth and lecture
me about why this particular unit why
Herodotus is cool just as I would hold
forth and lectured about why operating
systems are cool I there's it helped
reinforce this I having ideas from all
over the place that I can use for future
thanks also frankly prices math
department is outstanding III got our
and computer science as well I got a
very strong grounding in the
fundamentals of mathematics anyway and
and and the state of computer science at
that time happily computer sizes a young
in a field it was actually possible to
learn much of what there was I at the
time through thirty years ago and
certainly that served me very well I've
warned you all out but when you drop in
better or two apples how did they leave
them so the question is when I talk in
metaphor to venture capitalists how do
they take that and the answer is it is
one of the absolute best things to do
with Hydra capitalist is one of the
secrets and I've had a lot of practice
at this it's one of the secrets to doing
a great job with venture capitalists
it's it's it's it's in my opinion it's
the real reason they should believe me
not just the apparent reason that they
do it's why this technology is really
going to work and it isn't because of
the equation on the board it's because
of the idea that underlies that equation
I it helping that it helps them
understand for real because the metaphor
is the reality to remember me it helps
them understand for real why this is a
good idea and why it's going to work I
absolutely I depend on metaphor I in
especially with these very technical
things it communicated to the venture
capitalists it's been a successful
strategy for me but I would have to say
it's been a successful strategy for them
i think the right to to want the
metaphor and having been based in
Silicon played he's been a different for
you I'm sorry I didn't option but to
what extent home being based in Silicon
Alley made a different for you cannot
227 big business also made a difference
for me all right well I have to be based
anywhere else but my opinion is it's
been an enormous there
Silicon Valley is in an extraordinary
extraordinary place for all kinds of
different reasons a tremendous
assortment of people with passion and
technical expertise across the board a
whole venture capital infrastructure and
so on but to my own taste number one is
that Silicon Valley understands in a way
no other place I've ever been does that
the only crime is not to strive it's
consistent with my father's precept I've
always try your best I if in a more
conservative place like New York or
Switzerland not that I Love New York and
I love so everyone but but I if you fail
you look bad and you don't get money
again you don't get to try stuff again
and so there is a an ingrained fear of
failure that is to some extent rational
in Silicon Valley I if you really tried
hard if you built something interesting
and you really tried hard if it didn't
fly it didn't fly as long as you strove
as long as you really gave it everything
and had rational basis for believing it
was going to fly I the community in
Silicon Valley is forgiving in a good
way and says well you know you took a
real shot at this take a real shot at
something else and it might fly I think
I've never seen that anywhere else what
do you think computer chips will look
like in 20 years like quantum is that
going to be the future or so what do I
think computer chips will look like in
20 years is quantum computing the future
this is kind of a long long story let's
see what do I think I think a couple of
things to take to touch on quantum
computing first I do think quantum
computing will matter but I don't think
it's going to be everything I think
quantum computing will play some sort of
role in co-processing for specific
applications I'm not sure I believe
we've yet that quantum computing will be
will be everything but you know I would
be delighted to be wrong about that 20
years in eternity so it's hard to say
certainly well but I'll at least try
looking ahead say Oh 10 years which is
about about the best hope one might have
so I think so look and we'll have run
its course I think we'll be seeing
graphene or carbon nanotubes or some
other sort of carbon-based
scheme certainly I think we'll see three
dimensional assemblages we're seeing the
very beginnings of that already I to try
to make the wires shorter more important
than that i think that the philosophy of
computer architecture is going through a
significant change at something i myself
and trying to help facilitate but
whether tabular pulls this off or not i
think computer architecture from 10
years from now will be importantly
different from now the approach to
software will be importantly different
the i belief that will be able to take
up a Noman machine a serial
microprocessor latch a whole bunch of
them together in multi-core and that
someone's going to figure out how to
program it i think is nonsense that's
just not going to happen it's not going
to happen because it is non-physical to
pretend that it doesn't cost anything to
get data from a memory into a computing
element and that till that's accounted
for either in the programming model or
in the compiler or both I we will not be
able to scale computing and that's going
to change in the next 10 years don't
we're out okay sorry I know me go on for
an hour please join me
you